[MUSIC]
Welcome once again, I am Will Torres,
one of the admission officers here at
the Stanford Graduate School of Business.
First session, sharing your story I.
We going to talk about,
how do you start your story?
I was talking a lot about, think big,
what are some of the things that you wish
you can do if there was no expectation,
no fear of failure, what would you do?
From there, kind of unpacking the things
that really excite you to really get
an understanding of what that
path forward might look like for
you towards business school and beyond.
The analogy was the journey,
you're going to hear that word a lot.
What are the steps?
What did the path look like
to get from there to here?
What does that look like ahead of you?
What does that environment
around you look like?
How has that impacted who you are and
what that journey looks like?
So really thinking big.
What was your big picture?
From there,
we went right into the weave of,
how do you distill that into the written
portions of the application,
knowing that writing is beyond just
the essays, but technically you're
writing the resume and there are other
blank spaces throughout that you can
use in concert with each other, to help
build a clear picture of who you are.
How you're going to show up in
the classroom and in our community.
And today,
we're going to bring that to life.
Talking is going to be one
of the most energizing and
exhausting things you're probably
going to do in business school.
And a good chunk of that is
probably going to be covering or
sharing some part of your story.
So how do we think about that
during the application process?
And that is what we're
going to be focusing on today.
So, we're going to be talking
about how speaking and
sharing your story figures
into the application process.
We'll talk a little bit about that
tried-and-true tool, the elevator pitch.
And then tell me about a time when kind of
that infamous lead up to the thing that I
actually really love as well, apparently
I love a lot of things in admissions,
but the behavioral based interview.
That's the interview style that Stanford
uses and I want to give you a few tips and
things that I've observed
with my colleagues together.
We have maybe over a century
of admissions experience, and
this is put together from some of
the learnings we've had, observations and
things we would love to share with you.
And then we're going to
bring it full circle.
This is session three.
And so hopefully over the course of this,
we have given you the tools that
you might need so that you can try
different things, see what fits.
And as you go on, apply those both
in the application process and
hopefully in other places
in your life as well.
So a little bit of a disclaimer,
same disclaimer that I've
been giving all week long.
There's a lot of advice out there.
And I feel like especially around
the world of networking and
interviewing, there's so
many schools of thought out there.
Definitely, listen, see what's out there.
Find a process that works for you.
I know everybody has a different style,
everybody has a different strength.
And so as you explore and
test out different things,
find the spaces where you
feel the most comfortable.
Find the places, and even afterwards,
how do you recharge afterwards, right?
Because for some people,
this can feel like draining your battery,
and there are also ways to recharge it.
So let's play around,
see what we can find out.
So there's going to be two main parts
that we are going to be talking about,
networking and the interview.
So questions today,
we're going to be focusing on
these parts of the application.
Tomorrow we have another session
with Dean Moss, where we're going to
run the whole gamut of things from her
tips, what things has she seen over
the course of her career, and
what are we looking for in an application.
But right now, let's talk about
networking and the interview.
So, networking wise,
this can come in a lot of forms,
maybe you're talking to students,
maybe you're talking to alumni,
maybe you're talking to an admissions
officer at an event affair.
So many different spaces, this might crop
up and in ways you might not expect.
So one of the things that is going to help
carry through this, the elevator pitch.
When you meet somebody,
how do you leave that lasting impression?
It might be quick, but
you want it to be memorable.
These tends to be between 20
to 30 seconds long, again,
how long you might imagine
that elevator ride to be.
If you're in that crowded space,
how do you talk to that person so
you pique their interest?
How do you let them know what is special
about the thing you're talking about?
Maybe it's yourself.
How do you build that connection,
so that they say, hey,
let's connect after this,
I want to learn more.
That's where hopefully we're
going to try to get us today.
We're going to look at this elevator
pitch in a couple of different forms and
formats.
Try them on and
see what feels best for you.
So, here is a basic structure that I see,
I've heard this many,
many, many times, and
I think it's a great foundation.
I'm blank.
I'm originally from blank.
I went to school where I studied a topic.
I work at a company where I am currently,
this is my title.
I want to, here's my goal, and
this is why I'm interested in your school.
So if you have a paper and pencil handy,
maybe open up a browser so
you can type along, or
just think through it.
Sit down and write this out.
Write it out,
including your bits of information.
So for me, I'm Will.
I'm originally from California,
so on and so forth.
I'll give you a little
bit of time to do that.
This is going to be the foundation
of our first exercise.
So let me turn on my timer, I want to
make sure I'm giving you that full
minute [LAUGH] to jot all of this down.
So this is also going to be
an exercise in speed writing.
As you fill this out,
think through the times where you've
interacted with folks before.
Remember the times where
it felt successful.
Think about the times where you said,
that could have gone better, right?
Even as we practice some of those things,
I encourage you to step back and
think about the process.
As we were doing some of
the exercises in the other sessions,
I had that mental model,
did it go the way you thought it would?
How did it feel?
So even as you're doing the things here,
even as you're interacting and
trying them out in real time, it's
always worth stepping back to see okay,
let's analyze, let's learn,
and let's grow.
So, that's getting us to the minute.
This is your basic pitch,
great as a foundation.
So, we have it, here's our base, okay?
So, say yours out loud.
Maybe just whisper it if you're in
a place that might be strange, or
just read through it in your head and
listen to that mental voice.
This can often be a great structure, but
sometimes structures can also be limiting.
So, use this, but try your best
not to get too stuck if possible.
And here is a lie.
Sometimes there are going to be,
I might be talking to a lot of people and
the way to be memorable and
sometimes find that connection.
You might start with that one thread that
the other person can also associate with.
And from there that can open up
the conversation and help drive towards,
some kind of mini relationship that
kind of that could spark in the future
into something fruitful.
So, now let's do the elevator
pitch the remix.
Notice over the course of the week
I've been trying to instill
some activity today for sure there's
going to be a little bit of levity,
some humor because hopefully networking
well hopefully it's at least not a drag.
It might be fun, but
hopefully at least the interview
later on will be fun for you.
And that's what we strive for.
So I want the prep for
you to be enjoyable as well.
So, let's get to that remix,
we're talking about connection.
Sometimes you can flip around
the pieces of your basic pitch, so
that start with that spark.
And that actually opens up the door.
So here's another form of it.
So go ahead, write your pitch again,
this time start with,
maybe the institution that you went with.
And notice how there's that too.
That's already including the other person.
It's building some kind of rapport even
though they haven't yet engaged with you.
When you say you majored in or
kind of whatever structure you
have as part of your basic pitch,
that can also be somewhere where
you add a little bit of flavor.
Notice I put the dot dot
dot that ellipses there,
because maybe that could be some
observation of something from your school.
Maybe it could be some observation
from something in your,
from your career, whatever it
is that shared connection like.
This is often helpful if you know
that person or you know that kind of
the environment that you might be
heading into, or as you practice,
hearing it or it comes up in conversation,
being able to adapt on the fly.
Hopefully get that gave you enough time
to rewrite your pitch buying that point
of connection.
You're going to write
your pitch one more time.
Sometimes the best thing that you can
connect with someone over is a shared
interest.
Or even a interest maybe you
don't know what shared just yet.
But when I'm at fairs and people talk
about their interest, that's where like,
maybe you might be interested in this or
I've heard about that.
Tell me more.
That is often an opening for conversation.
And this is one of the ways that
I like to approach networking.
I'm honestly really bad at it.
I might be okay talking to a screen.
I'm fine when it comes to speaking and
connecting with people so
that I can help out and be of service.
But when I'm trying to do something for
myself or
build towards something
it feels really awkward.
And I know that might be similar to,
for some of you out there, but
if you flip networking and the elevator
pitch on its head and think about it.
Hey, let's figure out a shared interest
sparked that mini relationship and
see where it goes from there.
It might make things easier, and you might
actually meet some really cool people who
beyond whatever the intent of that
networking event might have been,
end up being some really good friends.
So how are we going to approach this?
That interest Pathway, so I'm blank.
I'm interested in this and
then feel free to stop after that one.
It's going to be the same kind of
lines after that, but go ahead and
take a moment and figure out okay,
what is something you are interested in.
Especially as it pertains
to business education.
I know in the past people
have been talking about, Hey,
I'm interested in clean energy.
Maybe it's some of the things that
you spoke about in the q&a box
earlier when you're
introducing yourselves.
Maybe it's talking about passion for
making education accessible
in Central America.
So even as you're thinking about your
motivations, that can be something you
share up front, so
that you can build that relationship and
already kind of cut to the chase without
having to kind of dance around the bush.
So here's an example.
We're going to add a call to action
to also give it that extra up.
So that it's an invitation for engagement.
So, now we get to the example.
So here's my I'm Will,
I'm originally from California,
I went to UCLA where I
studied marine biology.
I work at Stanford where
I'm an admissions officer.
I want to grow as
an admissions professional and
this is why I'm interested in your school.
Take a moment.
Feel that out.
It was fine.
You might know something about me now.
And are you necessarily interested?
Maybe, maybe not.
Let's try the remix.
I will.
I went to UCLA to I majored in marine
biology like way off in South Campus.
What about you?
That could be a spot for conversation?
I'm originally from California,
and then you can go from there.
Already you're opening it up for
conversation.
As you think about hey,
I want to UCLA too.
Notice how your body
might also react to that.
When you're in that script mode,
sometimes it becomes so
memorize that it just comes out.
And it's hard to emote, right?
It's hard to connect when you're just
hitting some high level bullet points.
But as you start talking about experience,
the emotion and
body language starts to pick up.
And isn't that part of how
relationships and talking?
Are you?
Hopefully you're finding
some engagement that way.
And then when you talk about interest,
maybe you really do like let's
talk about the interest approach.
Hi, I'm Will, I'm really interested in
making business school accessible by
democratizing access to
application information.
I really want to continue growing
as an admission professional and
that's why I'm interested in your school.
So take a moment out of that land.
Compare that to hi I'm well,
I'm originally from California.
I went to UCLA and
I studied marine biology
Two kind of different approaches
towards some same goal.
One, I don't quite know where
you're going through to yet.
The other hey, especially if it's on
topic if it's something related to where
we are or you something that you're
interested in connecting over, hey, no,
maybe this person has that spark and
let's continue from there.
So, take a look at the three
of yours right now.
Take a moment, read through them.
If you have the ability to
read them out loud, once,
I kind of feel it, see how you
feel as you're reading them, okay?
If you're not in a place where
you're able to vocalize.
Read it and listen to that
internal voice in your head.
Which one of these three is the one
that you feel most connected to?
Which one feels the most natural to?
One is not necessarily more or
less effective than the other.
Each might have its turn.
And I want you to be able to
navigate between the three of them.
So that depending on what situation
you're in, you're able to adapt and
pick which tool within your
toolkit you're going to use.
So I'm going to give you
a little bit of time so
you can actually hear the voice
inside of your head and not mine.
Hopefully you're able to at least give
some of those, a little bit of a try.
From one end of the spectrum there's
a little bit more of that monologue from
the other end there's that dialogue.
If you add a call to action at the end,
that's often an opening for conversation.
And conversation can really continue and
that's again,
another one of those threads that maybe
makes kind of creating that mosaic and
landscape of the things that you're
interested in that much clearer.
So, let's start to bridge
that over into the interview.
So networking, thinking about the elevator
pitch kind of expansive can be used in
many applications.
So let's talk a little bit
more about the interview.
And I'll start with there's
a couple of questions here.
So let's knock out some of the logistics
questions as we get started.
So Stanford we do use
behavioral based interviews.
Typically there's about two to three
interviews for every spot in the class.
So that means not everybody's
going to be interviewed.
But if you are interviewed,
hey, that's a great sign.
These are conducted mostly by our alumni.
Sometimes our admission officers, there
have been times where I've been able to do
interviews, and
I always really enjoy them.
Being able to hear about your
experiences from your own voice and
perspective is so enlightening, and
I find a very valuable part of
the whole application process.
Applications are also kind of holistic,
not kind of they are holistic
when we're doing these reviews.
And sometimes it might feel because this
is a step after you've submitted that
this might be a make it or
break it instance, and it's not that way.
After your interview,
we will receive the report and
then take that look at
the whole document again.
Take a look at all of the different
pieces of your application to see, hey,
where does intellectual vitality
demonstrated leadership potential and
personal qualities and
contributions shine for this individual.
And then we make
the decision on the whole.
So, that's a little bit
about the logistics of it.
So by nature also these invitations for
interviews come a little bit after
we start reading, we have to be able to
start making some of those assessments and
they do come through on a rolling basis.
We try your best to be as
communicative as possible,
through the application process so
you know what to expect.
I understand that as you're waiting,
because there is no set day when you
may get that interview invite that
anxiety and stress might build.
And if you put your best foot forward,
hopefully you're proud
of where you are and
just get excited about the potential
rather than waiting on the anxiety.
So might be very easy for me to say on
this side of the table, but give it a try.
So let's talk more about the interview.
Tell me about a time when this is
really the core question kind of
the fundamental basis of the behavioral
based interview has performance
as a great indicator for
how you might behave again in the future.
So at the beginning,
bringing him back to the story and
why it's part of this
sharing your story series.
You've had an opportunity to think big.
What are the things that
you're looking towards?
What is on your horizon?
For traditional interviews,
you are going to be asked about
your opinions, your thoughts,
maybe there might be a hypothetical
situation or something along those lines.
At Stanford we're going to be focusing
on behavioral basic questions.
We're really going to be
asking you about your past.
The footsteps that you've
gotten to get here.
What did that path look like?
What was the environment and
the circumstances that shaped the way
that you got to where you are today?
So really specific anecdotes,
examples and experiences.
The great thing about this is that
you are already the expert in you.
And so from here it's not about
having to think forward and hey,
does this plan make sense?
But really think backwards,
reflect and remember.
So, here are a few tips and
best practices as we enter the process.
So, remember, reflect, process, connect,
uses this phrase at least once
in each one of the sessions.
Remember instances from your past,
reflect on the circumstances around it.
What led to it?
What happened?
Who was involved?
Process, how did that
connect to the greater whole?
What were the things that you did?
The how's and the whys.
Now that hindsight is 2020.
Let's process the way those
things work together.
So you actually got from point A to point
B, or maybe you got from point A to
lowercase a stalled a little bit,
went back to the drawing board and
then got to a different version of B and
then connect.
Connect the dots between
the different things.
If there was learning that happened where
else might you have applied that learning?
Have there been themes?
How did that theme emerge?
Or if there was a really important
strategic insight you had,
did you have another one?
Where was it?
What were the things that kind of
sparked that experience for you?
So, remember, reflect, process, connect.
So a non exhaustive list of things
that you might want to think about,
how do you narrow down that list
of possible life experiences that
you want to like brush up on?
So a few things to think about.
What are things that you're proud of?
This can be both in your professional
life, your personal life,
the things that you do extra curricularly.
Remember when we talked about intellectual
vitality demonstrated leadership,
potential and personal qualities and
contributions as being background
agnostic and context dependent?
They can emerge, these competencies
can emerge anywhere in your life.
So really lean into that.
Try to think first what are some things
that in the last few years, just because
those are some of the freshest and
probably the easiest examples to remember.
That said, maybe you did something really
needy and some something it's really proud
of, but maybe it was a little
bit more distant in your past.
That's okay as well.
And, you might also be asked, what about
something a little bit more recently.
So definitely share if that experience
was very meaningful for you.
And just be ready with a few others in
your back pocket to explore
with whoever your interviewer.
The other question I often get is, should
I have a lot of different experiences?
And should I answer each question
with a different experience?
Or is it okay to stay with one.
And it is okay to stay with one.
Some examples can be really meaty.
There might be different
ways that you discuss
it based on the question
that's being asked.
So lean into whichever feels comfortable.
Listen to the question.
The question will help guide you.
That's what the interviewer is there for.
Hopefully this is a conversation and
the questions are just that spark for
where that dialogue can occur, so
that we can learn more about you and
try to pull out those pieces of
excellence, those competencies so
that they can share it back with
us as an admissions committee.
So, what are other things to
consider as you are going through
this remember, reflect,
process, connect, like cycle.
Take me there.
This was my project that work,
here's the situation.
We're really taking you there,
who is involved?
Who are the stakeholders?
How did you feel when things happen?
Remember, some of these details and
even though they might feel a little,
really nuanced and fine grain,
just sit yourself back into that example.
And if you are able to remember
it with that vibrancy,
close your eyes, that big picture.
If you close your eyes and
see yourself there again,
I think you're heading
in the right direction.
Let me see it through your eyes and
hear through your words.
So don't just remember, but
practicing verbalizing,
what that situation was, okay, STAR.
So this is one of those structures
that is really powerful.
It's a common framework for how to respond
to almost any, [LAUGH] interview question,
really?
So situation task, action, result.
I'm not really going to go much into
detail here because there's a lot of
really great content that you
can discover on your own.
And I do encourage you to look at
different frameworks out there and
put on the ones that feel right for you.
But I will talk about is something
that I kind of refer to as STAR+.
What does that mean?
So even as you're thinking about
the situation, task, action, result.
There are extra elements that
might be handy and helpful for
us in the process, right?
So context,
was it the first time you did something?
Was it the first time
your team did something?
Was it the first time your company did it?
Was it the first time this
was done in your industry?
That context like that
can be very helpful.
Remember how as part of that background
agnostic context dependent piece was.
Context is a really helpful piece of the
evaluative process for us to understand,
what was the landscape
you were navigating,
as you were expressing some
of these competencies?
So help us understand,
what was the context for this example?
We talked a lot about impact,
was there scope scale?
Why was it important?
What was the significance of
this instance or this outcome,
whoever was impacted by it?
And then so what?
Take a step back and think, okay,
how does this connect, right?
Why is this important to me?
There's a purpose that there's
a reason why I'm talking about this.
So let's feel good about that?
And then connect that back because
that's the way you're going to really
be able to anchor in the things that
are the most meaningful for you.
And those are the examples that hopefully
you're most likely going to be able
to articulate, remember, and
kind of delve deeply the best, right?
The things that are meaningful for you,
the things that have really made
an impression on who you are.
You might be asked kind of to switch
midstream, give us a different detail.
So that's also part of that comfort
level of knowing your whole story,
that if we asked you to look to the left,
you're able to.
And then you're still able to talk about
the rest of that image because you live
that experience, you are the expert in it.
So these next two,
we're going to do a little bit of a pilot.
We've never done this before,
and I can definitely say
I've never done this before.
But since we aren't able to interact and
I'm not able to give feedback to you
directly, I am going to do
a little bit of a demo.
So I know someone said earlier
that they are into improv comedy.
Please don't judge me too harshly,
[LAUGH] on this, but
this is also my first time with improv.
I'm going to give you
a little bit of time.
In the Q&A box,
can you please put a profession and
tell me about a time when situation
give me an interview question.
Tell me a time when you have
something you're proud of,
tell me about a time
when you were challenged.
So I'm going to give you all 30 seconds,
profession, and
an example you would like me to unpack for
you, so here we go 30 seconds.
I see at least one in there,
let's get those come in through ice, okay?
I'm loving some of these, got about
ten more seconds to put something in.
Right, in 3, 2, 1, and please stop typing.
Okay, this next piece, we're going to
make use of that up vote button, so
things might be flying
a little quickly here.
What I'm going to do is actually have two
things that I'm going to demo for you,
have the top five things
that get up voted.
I'm going to choose two for each demo.
So for the top five,
I'll be doing two of them.
So I'll give you,
[LAUGH] about a minute because it
takes a little bit of time to scroll
through, find one that you enjoy.
But I'll give everyone a minute to
look at the different sessions and
questions about notice I'm already
getting kind of nervous here,
so, [LAUGH] have at it and
I am going to go off-screen for a second.
So I can take a deep breath and
a drink of water.
All right, keep those up votes come in.
We'll leave voting open for
another 10 seconds or so.
All right, and go ahead and start,
let me take a look through and
see what the top five are.
So, [LAUGH] from Leah Crown,
tell me about a time you have failed.
Would anyone tell me your most challenging
customer experience, these are good.
Zookeeper tell me about a time when you
had to deal with a difficult conversation
with a co-worker and finance.
Tell me about a time you had
an ethical challenge, all right?
So for each of these demos,
I'm going to do it twice.
So each is going to demonstrate one thing
for you to consider, maybe as a way to
help kind of guide you through this
process as you answering questions.
So these could be things that you try on
as you're in the interview or in practice.
So the first I'll do clown,
tell me about a time you failed, okay?
So here we go.
So there was this one time we were
at a party and people came out and
we were really excited, but
then Iceland did sweating and
I forgot what I was supposed to say and
I kind of started stumbling.
And I couldn't remember anything..
Nobody laughed, and
I think that was one of the most hurtful
kind of embarrassing moments of my life.
And from there I really took it on to say,
hey, maybe I should take a little bit of
the pressure off of myself and
approach it and have fun myself.
I'm a clown and
it should be all about having fun, okay?
Hopefully that works, okay,
we're going to try this again So
I'm a clown and in my career,
it's all about how you make people laugh.
And this one time, crickets, we went out.
I was so nervous because I really wanted
to make sure people were having a good
time at this event.
Nothing, no laughter, not even a chuckle.
Maybe the only laugh was an embarrassed
laugh and someone embarrassed for me.
I knew then and there that maybe I
had to rethink how I approach things.
I should be having fun as well.
And so that was one of my biggest
learnings here from that failure,
to have fun, because if I'm not
having fun, you're not having fun.
Okay, two different ways of
answering the same question.
Maybe not as interesting as you
might have been expecting given that
we're in an interview.
And you might be talking about
any professional experience.
But in the first,
I just kind of started talking.
I actually started rambling and found
myself going in a different direction.
So I caught myself and
brought me back to the question at hand.
The second, I mapped it out for you.
I told you what my job was, what I was
going to talk about what that failure was.
I told you about the failure, and then I
told you the learning from the failure.
If you map it out, it has this nice
effect of both keeping you inbounds.
So having a nice starting point,
as well as an ending point.
And that can be really helpful for
folks who tend to weave
very elaborate stories or
tend to continue beyond your point.
And it helps your interviewer already
understand where this is going.
On a map, you have a starting point and
an end point.
Give them the lay of that land and
map it out for them so
that they know which
parts to be looking for.
In that first question,
you might have been waiting for, hey,
what's the point here?
Whereas in the second one,
that point was a lot easier to pick up and
also a lot easier to
communicate from my end.
So give that a try.
Okay, so this next one,
let's see, where did it go?
We're going to do the zookeeper one
time I had a difficult conversation with
a coworker.
And clearly, I'm a little bit here,
so I was going to choose that one.
I'm so happy it jumped into
the top five so I could.
Okay, here we go.
So this one time we were at the zoo,
where we were working,
and we had this really strange
incident that kept happening.
We kept finding the antelope
with the lions.
And every day, every night,
that was something that kept happening.
We didn't know where it was coming from.
We launched an investigation.
Cameras were broken, so that didn't help.
Finally, we figured out that
it was one of our coworkers.
They thought it was really cute to
have a whole Safari in one space.
And we had to talk to them and
tell them that wasn't possible and
that we had to let them go.
So I'm going to stop story there.
Next, let me try that again.
So I'm a zookeeper.
And we had a difficult conversation
that I had to really take the lead on.
Well, there was a period of time where we
kept finding the antelope with the lions,
which didn't always turn out well for
the antelope.
So I launched an investigation.
I tried to think, what are the different
ways that this could happen?
I tried to look into the cameras'
situation, but those were broken.
And we realized after
talking to a number of folks,
I was able to trace it back
to one of my coworkers.
I talked to management and he said,
this is one of your direct supervisees.
You're going to need to tell
them we have to let them go.
So I had the really difficult situation of
telling someone who really loved their job
and really wanted to create a fun, lively
[LAUGH] exhibit that they were fired.
Okay, hopefully those two
situations illustrated
something that came out maybe clearly.
As an interviewer,
I do start to pick it up.
There's a difference between we and
I, right?
There is no I in team, but
there is an I in admit.
And I'm just kind of joking
with this kind of phrase,
but there is some truth to it as well.
I'm guilty of this.
I talk in the we all the time.
The last time I interviewed within
the office, Dean Moss was my interviewer.
And she said, Will, you keep saying we.
What did you do?
And so I encourage you as you're thinking
about these examples, what did you do?
Even if it was a group exercise,
if it was a group that got from point
A to point B, you had some role in there.
What was your contribution?
Was it the idea?
Was it the late night that really
got you to that breakthrough?
Was it engaging and getting the senior
administration on board with you?
So it's okay to talk about I, right?
I know I mentioned in other sessions that
sometimes there is a cultural element.
Maybe it's a community or family or
personal kind of situation where you
don't really talk about yourself.
This is one of those times that I
encourage you to embrace that discomfort.
And if you catch yourself going there,
it's always okay to name it.
Name it to yourself because once you
name something, you're able to say, hey,
okay, now we can work
towards addressing that.
So take me there, walk me and
talk me through all the details.
STAR, situation, task, action, result.
STAR+, give me some of that context as
you're planning or remembering things.
What were the circumstances
that surrounded it?
What were some of those ripple effects?
Map it out.
Let me know as your interviewer
where you're going to go with.
Let me know so
that I can be paying attention and
really focus on the details and
the competencies that come
out rather than trying to figure out
where we're going with the story.
Center yourself, and
that is a phrase that I've been saying
pretty consistently through the week.
Even though we do celebrate collaborative
effort, and the GSB is definitely one
of those places where collaboration
is part of the experience, right?
How do you support others and challenge
each other to grow to the fullest extent?
I mean, the policy of grade
non-disclosure really exemplifies that,
not publishing lists of GPA or
class rank to recruiters.
This frees you to help each other,
to ask for help, and
to create that support network so
you're always lifting each other up.
And you're part of it and you should
be the center of this discussion.
So don't worry about not feeling
like you're being a teammate by
using the phrase I.
I really do want to know about
what you did and how you did it.
So networking, interview,
two parts of the application process
that are going to be really dependent and
really fueled by your voice.
So definitely practice.
Find someone you trust.
Maybe this is an instance where you
practice on that networking site.
Invite someone at work to a one-on-one so
you can learn more about their kind
of job responsibilities and role.
Sometimes low-key interviewing like
that will help you as someone who's
speaking on the other end feel comfortable
about, this is just a conversation.
Talking to people really
does help with this.
And I know that might be exhausting for
some, it might be energizing for others.
So find those times where you're
willing to exert that and
find those times where you an honor
the times you just need to recharge.
And this brings us here.
When I started, in admissions, like I,
there was a lot of learning.
I realized that as I was growing up
I knew actually nothing about what it
meant to apply to college,
or even grad school.
It often felt like looking back there
might have been some kind of hidden
curriculum to, how to get in and
how to thrive.
And so
my goal with the events this week and
my goal with the sharing your story
series was to illuminate the process so
that you can put your best foot forward so
that you can understand both our process.
Just to be comfortable and know that
there is a system that cares takes this
very seriously and is rooting for you and
know what's on your side of the net.
Understand the things that
are under your control and
the things that you are able to like
shape and shine and really mold into
something that you are proud of
when you click that Submit button.
The goal of application week was to help
you figure out the ways pick up some
frameworks, some tools and
things that you can experiment with.
So that you can again,
put your best foot forward and
see where this journey will take you.
This slide is, a little anti climatic and
that's on purpose.
This is just one step of your journey,
and maybe the least exciting step,
probably the least exciting step.
You have business school ahead of you.
If you're not going to business school,
maybe whatever career path you're going
on some of these things might be helpful.
What matters exercise those five why's
can help you figure out, should I move?
Should I take this job?
What will that opportunity look like for
me, what is my north star?
And so hopefully, this is again,
just the beginning of that crazy canvas,
and that big picture that you're
going to be able to explore.
And that horizon that you're
going to be able to reach towards.
So I'm going to leave you all with this.
It's an inscription on the cornerstone
of GSB campus and I'm going to just
read it word for word because it is that
meaningful and that meaningful for me.
Dedicated to the things that
haven't happened yet, and
the people who are about to dream them up.
Your dream big.
All right, with that,
I'm going to take a moment.
Go ahead and go into the Q&A box,
answer whatever questions you might have.
And I also really encourage you all
to tune in tomorrow to the dean's
office hours with Kirsten Moss.
It's a fireside chat where
I'm going to be just.
Shooting the breeze with the Dean of
MBA admissions and financial aid.
To really get her perspective
on this whole application during
the journey that I hope that
you have enjoyed so far.
And even if you decide,
maybe this is the end of my journey,
that it was enjoyable and fruitful.
So here's the question.
Is networking with current
Stanford students and
alumni important to
the admissions process?
And how is that shown in the application?
And so my favorite part of this
answer is no, you do not have to have
interacted with any student or alum or
even attended a Stanford event.
We do not practice what's
called demonstrated interest.
Are you submitting your
application that's,
all you need to let us know that you're
interested in applying and attending.
So please don't feel any pressure that
you have to reach out, talk to someone,
especially if there's no one in your
network or you don't have the time or
resources to do so.
That is not a part of the process at all.
We're here hosting events so hopefully
we can help you, kind of, understand and
feel comfortable and
confident as you go through the journey,
and that's all these events are for.
So, no, you do not have to
interact with us at all [LAUGH]
question about managing vulnerability.
I want to talk about the past to take in,
and what our circumstances and
histories in play.
How do we look at difficulties, setbacks,
objectively negative experiences
such as work injuries?
Some stories have uglier elements and
others but
the learnings may be significant and
shareworthy.
You caught it at the end and
you said it I think way more
beautifully than I could have.
The learnings may be significant and
shareworthy.
If those learnings are,
then they are significant, right?
Those are the things that
you want to anchor on.
Let us know enough about the situation
that we understand what was going on.
So if it was a work injury,
maybe that's where you can leave it.
You don't need to go
into the grisly detail.
So keep it at the level.
Also read the room, I think that's
going to be one of those things
that you're also going to be
getting a lot of practice with.
For some folks like with me,
you might get the sense that it's,
you can go there and go ahead.
And with others, you might feel like, hey,
we don't have that relationship just yet
in this time and space.
Let's keep it a little bit
more high level on detail.
But really going on the learnings.
So it's also going to be a little bit of
dialogue between you and the person and
you and yourself.
See how you're feeling in that moment.
Let's see question about
about the demo [LAUGH].
Hopefully it was more clear
than it sounded coming,
then it sounded coming out of my mouth.
For questions around failure or mistake,
is it better to include evidence of
how you've improved in addition
to what you've learned?
I would say sometimes yes.
Sometimes though it's case dependent,
right?
If that is the point of it.
So maybe the question is, hey,
can you tell me about a time
where you've had a failure?
And what did you learn from it?
Usually there's going to
be some cue there.
That will let you know okay, should we be
talking about the learning or should we
be talking about the growth sometimes
that learning and growth go hand in hand.
If there's time, if there's space,
if you feel like you haven't gone on for
too long, go ahead and
share those extra elements with us.
What I will say is and this is where
he said it might be case dependent.
Sometimes folks might go for
an extended period of time.
I have definitely [LAUGH] had interviews
where I asked one question and these these
are 45 minute interviews 45 to an hour,
and I only got through two questions.
So also be conscious of the time
it should be a conversation.
And so, if you have a time,
take that pause.
See where the conversations going.
If you have that room go there,
if not allow your interviewer to help
guide you on what they're trying
to pick up on because we will.
Thank you everyone for joining us.
I am so proud to have been able
to premier application weekend,
but share your story of series with you.
I hope you have found this helpful.
Please go ahead and share any key of
the point have with us in the pool.
If you have any questions, commentary,
things that you would like
to see us do in the future.
Let us know email us,
that's the way I learned what
the things we should be doing are.
So any guidance from you insights,
inspiration, here's the innovation and
here's to dreaming big and doing better.
So with that thank you all.
I hope to see you around soon.
Stay safe.
And remember, dream big, y'all.
[MUSIC]